on va voir si vous êtes d'accord sur le
deuxième thème de ce club on va parler
du fond Marianne Samia la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur le fond Marianne
a terminé ses auditions mais le rapport
n'est pas encore sorti il est attendu
dans les prochains jours il s'annonce en
barre à 100 pour la ministre Marlène
Schiappa oui puisque le sénateur
Jean-François Husson qui rapporte cette
commission d'enquête l'accuse de ne pas
avoir dit la vérité lors de son audition
au Sénat c'est ce qu'il a déclaré dans
une interview au journal l'Est
Républicain voici ses propos exacts que
je vais vous lire elle ne m'a pas
convaincu l'audition de Marlène Schiappa
a montré plus que des dysfonctionnements
à sa place je démissionnerai notre
rapport conclura qu'elle ne dit pas la
vérité mais la justice sera son travail
derrière car nous ne sommes pas des
juges voilà pour les propos donc de
Jean-François ils sont dans l'Est
Républicain il ne dit pas clairement
qu'elle a menti mais il le sous-entend
un peu quand même il est revenu pour
nous hier sur ses propos au micro
d'Adrien pas regardez
et après avec la vérité voilà puisque la
vérité les plaines entières et il y a à
mon avis plusieurs
comment dirais-je plusieurs de ces
prises de position qui vont se trouver
prises à défaut je crois qu'il
l'audition du de mercredi matin a bien
démontré certaines de ces incohérences
ce sera donc inscrit un noir sur blanc
visiblement dans le rapport que le Sénat
doit rendre public je le rappelle à la
mi-juillet cette commission elle enquête
sur les conditions d'attribution du fond
Marianne créée après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty les sénateurs cherchent à
faire la lumière sur des soupçons de
favoritisme et de mauvaises utilisations
des fonds alors Samir sur quoi porte ces
incohérences alors il ne le dit pas
encore vraiment précisément
Jean-François Husson il faudra donc
attendre la mi juillet pour le savoir
avec la publication du rapport mais en
fait on connaît déjà pour ceux qui ont
suivi les auditions un peu les
incohérences qui ont été pointées lors
de l'audition de Marlène schia notamment
sur la tribution pardon d'une subvention
à SOS Racisme l'association aurait
d'abord été sélectionnée pour recevoir
100.000 euros avant que la subvention
soit finalement annulée par la ministre
le directeur de cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa assure qu'elle est intervenue
personnellement pour annuler cette
subvention en raison d'un différent avec
son président auditionner un peu plus
tard elle nie tout implication regardez
leurs deux déclarations contradictoires
nous avons sur cette association
une réserve de la de la ministre en
raison d'un historique de relations
assez ancien donc il y a bien eu sur les
décisions arrêtées comme ici sélection
pour l'un de ces lauréat
une affirmation par la ministre
directeur de cabinet fait état de
relations personnelles ou de désaccord
personnel que j'aurais avec monsieur le
Président de SOS Racisme je n'ai pas là
non plus on me prête beaucoup de
relations personnelles mais je n'ai pas
de relation personnelle ni de désaccord
personnel anciens ou récent avec
monsieur le Président de SOS Racisme et
Samia que risque Marlène Schiappa si
elle a menti à la commission d'enquête
il y a théoriquement jusqu'à 50 prisons
et 75000 euros d'amende pour faux
témoignage le Sénat peut engager des
poursuites contre elles c'est déjà
arrivé c'était en 2015 lors d'une autre
commission d'enquête sur le coût de la
pollution de l'air devant les sénateurs
le pneumologue Michel Aubier a affirmé
sous serment et qu'il n'avait aucun lien
avec l'industrie pétrolière or il était
salarié de Total en tant que médecin
conseil le verdict est tombé en 2018 on
appelle et Michel Aubier a été condamné
à 20000 euros d'amende voilà ça risque
de passer devant la commission d'enquête
du Sénat on le voit le rapport s'annonce
à blanc pour Marlène Schiappa il
conclura qu'elle ne dit pas la vérité
c'est ce que dit le rapporteur est-ce
qu'elle peut rester en place Marlène
Schiappa
si vous permettez d'abord dire que
d'abord souligner la qualité de cette
commission d'enquête je l'ai suivi grâce
à vous et enfin la plupart des
interventions et c'est c'était fait avec
avec respect avec professionnalisme
façon éthique
et ça fait surgir un certain nombre de
peut-être de mensonges en tout cas
sûrement de contre de contradiction
extrêmement forte mettez-moi d'en
ajouter une j'ai été frappé que l'un des
principaux bénéficiaires de ce fond
Marianne version
Marlène Schiappa au minimum en tant que
ministre
Mohammed Sifaoui se soit permis de faire
preuve ce qui lui est assez naturel
d'ailleurs d'une arrogance incroyable
vis-à-vis des sénateurs et tout ça donne
une impression
pénible désagréable il faut que toutes
les conséquences politiques et en soi en
soi tiré au-delà des questions de
personnes elle s'existent qui paiera la
note on verra il faut que toutes les
parce que on serait oublier que c'est le
fond Marianne a été créé à partir de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et pour
donner un nouvel élan plus fort et
différent à la lutte contre les le
terrorisme on va dire ça comme ça je
pense que c'est pas inadéquat de dire ça
comme ça donc un sentiment profond de
malaise alors après le destin de Marlène
Schiappa ou de où je sais pas ou de X ou
Y on verra mais mais
les sénateurs ont fait on fait
des vérités dérangeantes dont il faudra
tirer les conclusions
prête à vouloir étonner son public je
l'invite à venir s'exprimer dans les
pages de politique pour annoncer sa
démission et présenter ses excuses aux
français
[Musique]
de gauche se venir s'excuser et annoncer
sa démission non franchement là aussi
c'est pareil on parlait de démocratie
tout à l'heure mais vous voyez tout est
démocratie européenne notamment les
démocraties du Nord sur ce type
d'affaires évidemment elle se elle
démissionne elle elle fragilise
énormément déjà qu'il est quand même
particulièrement fragilisé ce
gouvernement elle fragilise beaucoup
ce gouvernement et puis effectivement
moi aussi qui est suivi avec attention
ces auditions on voyait bien la gêne et
l'absence de cohérence dans le propos de
Marianne Schiappa qui était obligé voilà
je sais pas comment vous avez vu aussi
la qualité de la conduite de cette
commission d'enquête
dites-le je partage positives de temps
en temps j'ai le sentiment qu'il a
découvert une vocation de notre ami
Dominique
président de la collection pas du tout
simple je suis capable d'admiration j'ai
été bluffé je suis d'accord moi aussi
j'ai été bluffé
chacun membre de la commission je trouve
non non mais j'allais venir en plus
c'est vrai je reconnais que tout c'est
ils avaient connaissance du dossier ils
savaient répondre ils savaient ils ont
gardé leur calme face à moi qui était
absolument sidérant de mieux pris pour
les représentants du peuple violence
grenade je me suis pas assez solide là
on était dans une chose très politique
mais pour quelqu'un qui était censé être
en charge justement de la prévention de
la radicalisation quand j'ai vu
intervenir monsieur Sifaoui je me dis
mais ce type est tard est un radicalisé
de oui ce monsieur si vous préférez j'ai
tellement j'ai un langage
oui mais pour en revenir à Marlène Chapa
oui vous prenez toutes les démocraties
modernes il y a longtemps que elle
serait plus membre de ce gouvernement
donc elle qui est sipron t'a donné des
leçons en permanence c'est vrai que là
elle est en difficulté et agir pour le
bien de ces petits camarades du
gouvernement déjà et puis oui pour avoir
vu le c'est ce que je commençais à dire
pour avoir vu les auditions on voit bien
la gêne qui était la sienne je ne sais
pas combien de fois elle a dit je vais
peut-être pas compris la question pour
éviter de répondre précisément en
question qui était les séries ou à
répondu à côté de la Pâques et désolé si
j'ai mal répondu parce que j'ai pas
compris la question enfin c'était
lunaire lunaire et encore une fois s'il
prend à être très précise tatillonne sur
les exigences qu'elle a sur les impôts
ou il est difficile de vous contredire
mais c'est merci on va encore être
d'accord on va encore être d'accord non
mais c'est différent
on débarque en souriant mais c'est vrai
que le sujet est grave elle dit vous
avez tous ces conneries on s'interroge
plus de savoir ce que j'ai signé ou que
ou de savoir qui finance il s'amuse mais
à qui la faute à qui la faute si c'est
si ce n'est pas la meilleure Marlène
Schiappa voilà je sais pas
de faire des choses intéressantes et
même percutantes là je dois dire qu'elle
est pour ceux qui l'ont qui ont apprécié
certains aspects de sa de sa conduite au
ministère et ils ont été j'en suis c'est
pas le sujet de l'émission du jour mais
vu qu'on est sur Marlène Schiappa vu que
vous avez c'est vous qui parlez d'elle
sans arrêt vous avez raison parce que
c'est le sujet c'est le sujet et ben je
sais pas si elle démissionnera dans les
jours à venir ou au prochain remaniement
qu'elle sera éjectée mais j'aimerais que
vous me disiez quel sera la marque
Schiappa qu'est-ce qu'elle aura laissé
en matière de police
je vois pas très bien quand elle était
ministre des femmes ou secrétaire d'État
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a jamais eu
d'exercice je vois pas très bien sur le
fond de cette commission puisque le
rapporteur Jean-François isson nous
disait il y a quelques jours que ce qui
s'est passé abîme les valeurs de la
République vous partagez ça
difficile de dire qu'en tout cas ça a
renforcé les valeurs de la République
non mais oui c'est encore une fois se
font et arrive sur un sur un acte
tragique et celui d'assassinat de Samuel
Paty avec une idée à l'origine qui est
plutôt bonne de favoriser des
associations qui vont intervenir pour
être prévention de la radicalisation
renforcer les valeurs de la République
et on a là une histoire politicienne
forfacheuse
et on suivra les suites de cette
commission d'enquête sénatorielle sur le
fond Marianne ça mais on regarde avec
vous ce qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce matin
[Musique]
Samia ce sont les orages qui font la une
de la presse régionale tout est ravagé
se désole le Berry Républicain les
témoignages des habitants de Preuilly
raconte un véritable chaos après le très
violente orage qui a frappé lundi cette
commune du Cher l'heure est au bilan et
il est très lourd 95% des habitations
sont touchées la mairie l'école l'église
aucun bâtiment ne semblait parier comme
si l'orage s'était acharné sur la
commune racontant un habitant tous des
règles s'inquiète aussi Sud-Ouest le
journal s'interroge ces violents orages
qui frappent la France depuis un mois
sont-ils le signe du réchauffement
climatique répond c'est-à-dire ce matin
dans les colonnes du Sud-Ouest Midi
Libre s'intéresse aujourd'hui au
business des paillotes un business très
rentable si jamais vous avez envie de
vous reconvertir Oriane on ne sait
jamais dans l'Hérault ça représente un
chiffre d'affaires de 52 millions
d'euros pour 70 paillots c'est le calcul
du préfet du département il faut dire
que le panier moyen des vacanciers dans
ces cabanes de plage peut atteindre 150
euros par endroits c'est dire si on est
prêt à dépenser pour se faire une place
au soleil sur les d'une paillote les
pieds dans l'eau on voit ça on a
toujours pas de nouvelles du Titan c'est
l'alerte lancée par Nice-Matin c'est la
malédiction du Titanic titre le journal
le sous-marin de tourisme a disparu je
le rappelle dimanche avec 5 personnes à
bord embarquées par 4000 mètres de fond
elle a découvertes de l'épave du Titanic
les forces armées américaines
canadiennes et désormais françaises
continuent de le chercher sous l'eau et
dans les airs une véritable course
contre la montre il ne leur reste que
quelques heures d'autonomie mais
visuellement on aurait entendu
aujourd'hui des bruits lors des
recherches des bruits sous l'eau
effectivement on termine par une
nouvelle plus optimiste allez c'est
aujourd'hui l'été oui c'est le 21 juin
et ce qui donne le coup d'envoi de l'été
c'est la fête de la musical est
largement relayée ce matin par la presse
régionale ça va être la fête près de
chez vous se réjouit La Voix du Nord une
fête brillante et vivante annonce le
Courrier Picard en avant la musique
lance Paris Normandie et bien on va les
prendre au moins Oriane et puis on va se
quitter en musique on a choisi la
chanson ensemble ce matin à la rédaction
avec Jonathan
voilà alors
anti-cuisse lequel de vous de reconnait
le premier ce type vous n'avez pas le
droit de jouer puisque vous avez choisi
[Musique]
la réponse
je ne sais pas si je le prononce
correctement
merci beaucoup Samia pour cette recette
on regarde la Une de Politis enfin
l'immigration
a proposé en matière d'immigration on
dit toujours la bouche n'a rien à dire
et bien on est allé enquêter on a une
analyse importante
merci beaucoup pierre Jacquemin merci
beaucoup Dominique de montfallon et
merci Samia très vite on se retrouve
demain 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
Thomas Huc pour science public et
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez voir revoir
cette émission c'est sur public c'est
n'importe quoi très bonne journée Adam
[Musique]